good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock and welcome wherever you're
joining us from this morning from
iceland to indonesia just one day to go
before voting starts in the local
elections and news this morning of the
latest squeeze on our pay package shop
prices rising at a rapid rate and the
cost of chicken on the prime minister's
mind so what are the government going to
do about it we'll ask the environment
secretary george eustis very shortly and
also the shadow chancellor rachel reeves
in the eight o'clock hour also today the
anger in america over a potential move
that would stop women being able to
choose to have an abortion will speak to
a republican strategist and a former
democratic member of the ohio senate who
have very different opinions it is
wednesday the 4th of may wait for it may
the 4th be with you
a special thank you a special report
from northern ireland
cost of living crisis deepens
as shop prices increase at their highest
rates in more than a decade with a
warning they could be worse to come
special report from northern ireland
ahead of elections there that could
prove pivotal if shin fein wins we speak
to locals
and i think the number one factor is
the living issue yeah the electric and
the gas what they do for my community
they don't do nothing for my community
they only come around the door when
they're looking their phone
left in hell as the first convoy of
civilians escape mario paul aid workers
worry for those left behind as ukrainian
officers claim russian forces are trying
to storm the steel plant
and as ukrainian forces continue their
fight in eastern ukraine there have been
new missile strikes in the western city
of levitt
[Music]
an assault on our freedom strong words
from the u.s vice president as protests
continue over a move to overturn a law
legalizing abortion
if the court
overturns roe v wade
it will be a direct assault on freedom
we reveal the murderers who could have
their prison sentence reviewed by senior
judges will either court
he would call the leading actor he would
call the director he would tell you i've
got eyes down there
the deputy heard libel case here's how
his controlling behavior allegedly gave
her ptsd as she tries to get the case
thrown out
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world some uk forecasters
predicting it beef and weather here on
the horizon later this week the new
research suggesting many of us avoid
sunscreen
we'll talk to a young man with incurable
skin cancer who wants people to protect
themselves better
[Music]
and i'll speak to two stars of a west
end production of cinderella who only
discovered the show had been cancelled
after seeing a post on social media
[Music]
good morning everybody making ends meet
will be at the front of many people's
minds with voting in the local elections
due to start tomorrow cost of living
crisis getting worse again with news
today of a record rise in the price of
household
goods well laura is in east london for
us this morning and however you look at
it whatever poll or report you're
reading it's getting worse
it is it really is deeping this cost of
living crisis and it isn't going to get
any better anytime soon with these
latest figures out looking at what we're
all paying for items when we go to the
shops when we go to the supermarket so
let's look at these latest figures now
retail prices k rose to 2.7
in april that's up from 2.1 in march
according to the british retail
consortium this was the highest annual
rate of inflation recorded since
september 2011.
food prices also increased they went up
by 3.5
in the year to april that's up from 3.3
in march and prices for products other
than food went up by 2.2 percent in the
year to april that's the highest rate
since records began back in 2006.
so what does it all mean well for
consumers for all of us when we go to
the shops it's simply going to cost more
money the head of the british retail
consortium is warning that things are
going to get worse before they get
better and that consumers we should all
be braced for a bumpy road ahead
okay for now thanks very much indeed
laura thank you should talk about that
in more detail with the government
minister this morning in the form of the
environment secretary george eustis mrs
thanks for joining us on the program
you're a farmer uh what difference have
you seen in rising costs
well the big impact on the farming
industry has really been the impact on
fertilizer costs and so there's always
been a very close correlation between
food prices internationally global
agricultural commodity prices and the
price of gas and oil and that's because
there's huge amounts of gas that goes
into manufacture fertilizers and so it
has a knock-on impact so farmers have
actually seen the cost of their
fertilizers treble in some cases
quadruple that's a really big increase
in their costs it's also led to
increased feed costs and that's like
that's starting to come through
the system now as some retail price
inflation what does that mean for us
when we go to the supermarket
well the um the better news is that we
have quite a very very competitive
retail market um you know with 10 big
supermarkets and the four main ones
competing very aggressively particularly
on some of the um you know the lower
cost uh everyday value items for
households so things like spaghetti and
ambient products there's a lot of
competition to keep those prices down
where it gets harder is on things like
chicken and poultry and some fresh
produce where those increased feed costs
do end up getting passed through the
system because these people work on
wafer thin margins and they have to pass
that cost through so what's your advice
to people then who want a sunday roast
with a chicken for the family but they
can't afford it
well the um the thing to bear in mind is
that if you look at household spending
on food in the uk it's actually you know
the lowest in europe partly because
we've got uh that very competitive
market
it used to be for the poorest 20 of
households about 16
of their income used to go on food that
dropped a few years ago to about 14
it's going to rise again now but
generally speaking you know what people
find is that by going for some of the
sort of value brands rather than uh you
know own branded uh products they can
actually sort of contain and manage
their household budget but it will
undoubtedly put a pressure on household
budgets and of course it comes on top of
those high gas prices as well so if it
costs less than a fifth of the average
household budget are people
why are people telling us they have to
choose between heating and eating
well the the reality is that the the
price of food in and of itself doesn't
necessarily cause
uh poverty but obviously what does is if
you've got very sharp rises in people's
energy costs if it costs much more to
put petrol in the tank
if they've got housing costs going up
all of this adds to household pressures
and of course you know inability to buy
food or struggling to afford food is the
first thing that people notice because
it's something they need on a daily
basis and have to buy on a daily or
weekly basis so it's noticed first and
that's why you know we recognize that
it's why we've increased the national
living wage it's why we've made some
changes to benefits it's why we've
introduced uh some of those rebates to
try and help people with their energy
costs all of which will help people
through what is undoubtedly a
challenging time isn't it more chicken
and egg to go back to what you were
saying a few moments ago in that people
can't afford to put fuel in their
vehicle and if they do have to do that
in order to go to work then they don't
have enough money to buy food for the
kids at the weekends
well there's a cumulative impact to
inflation on households
budgets of course yes the government
does acknowledge that
rishi sunak absolutely acknowledged that
in his spring statement it's why
you know he made some changes to the the
planned national insurance so that uh
fewer people on low incomes would would
be paying that increase uh it's why
we've got the the 150 pounds council tax
rebate to give people an immediate uh
relief on their household budgets it's
why there's going to be a further 200
pounds rebate on energy coming later in
the year so there's a package of
measures we've put in place none of it
completely mitigates uh the impact but
all of it's designed to try and help
people through a challenging period and
it's also why a 77 year old woman
pensioner has to ride a bus all day to
keep warm because she can't afford to
heat the house
we'll look in addition to all the other
things that we're doing we've also got
uh we've increased the the funding in
the household uh support fund that's
given to local authorities we've got an
extra where is it obviously well we're
probably riding on a bus
exactly well i i feel if it was your
mother well in that particular case and
i i really um you know would advise uh
the woman in question to seek support
from her um from her um local authority
they they've been given now these these
household uh support funds specifically
to help those who fall between the
cracks so we've increased the national
living wage which helps people that are
working we've changed uh some of the
taper rate on universal credit to help
people are on benefits how would you
feel if it was your mother who was
riding around on a bus all day because
she couldn't afford to stay warm at home
well um if it were my mother then i
would um support her and go to the local
authority and try to get access to that
house it's her family's fault
well no but what i'm saying is if you're
you're asking me what my advice to her
is and my advice to her would be to go
to the local authority and try to get
some support from that household support
fund it's what it's there for we doubled
the fund to a billion pounds it's there
to support exactly cases like else's
when uh the prime minister was asked
about this uh yesterday he said oh yeah
well i introduced a freedom pass so she
won't have to pay for her travel on the
bus he actually didn't introduce the
freedom pass why would he say that
well look um the prime minister he gave
his interview i i'm not a um
precisely what he what he said he said
that he introduced the freedom pass on
the bosses and he didn't why would he
say it um well i i don't know i and i
he'll know better than any of us what he
might have done when he was uh london
mayor and some of the the measures that
he did absolutely speak a lot doesn't he
well uh i think the point here if you're
coming back to the original you know the
original question you had uh what would
my advice be to elsa well my advice to
it would be you know not to to stay on
on a bus all day to try and stay warm my
advice would be to seek some support
you know from the local authority and um
that's got a they've got a fund
specifically to help cases like here's a
thought why don't the government look at
a windfall tax um and then they will
have
an extra oh i don't know several billion
two billion or thereabouts in fact even
more than that to play with
well if you're talking about it on uh on
oil companies they already pay
a higher rate of corporation tax in
other companies around 10 percent higher
uh corporation tax if you look at bp um
they published good results yesterday
but they will pay around a billion
pounds in tax
on their north sea oil revenues well
they've also announced 18 billion
investment and and what we do need to
see from these companies given that we
still have north sea oil we need to see
them investing in that so that we said
they'll continue to do that in fact the
chief exec uh bernard looney said he
would continue to do that even if there
was a windfall tax
well all i would say is we've already
got a higher rate of tax for those
companies in north sea oil it's already
they pay enough tax well it's a
corporation tax it's already 10 higher
um we judge that's the right thing at
the moment we don't want to deter
investment um in the north sea uh
they're a big employer um bp um for
instance already saying it wouldn't
deter them but they would they would
continue to invest even if there was a
windfall tax george osborne did it so
why would you not do it do you feel they
pay enough taxes i'm sure you know
richie sunak will look at these things
and keep all of these things under
review and you know he was asked about
that this week and he said that's
exactly what he will do you know but for
now we judge yes it's right that these
oil companies pay more and they already
do pay more the headline rate of uh of
of income tax or corporation tax is
already 10 percent higher overall with
all the other levies and taxes are in
place they pay double the tax that most
companies would pay um you know if at
some point um there's a case for
reviewing that well obviously you know
rishi has got um budgets and autumn
statements or a budget coming up in the
autumn another statement coming after
that he obviously keeps the entire tax
regime under review all the time do you
feel that bp pays enough tax as of today
well as of today i understand it's going
to pay about a billion pounds in tax
well well oil companies if you're asking
me oil companies overall are paying
twice as much tax on their revenues my
question is do you think they pay enough
tax well for now yes and that's why
we've chosen not to do it because they
already pay a higher tax okay even
though they say
that if there was a windfall tax they
would continue to invest in the same um
what the projected investment would be
they would continue with that in the
united kingdom in the north sea uh oil
fields etc um and we have seen previous
governments do it previous conservative
governments including george osborne and
even going back to the 1980s margaret
thatcher
introduced a windfall tax when she felt
that banks were making too much profit
on interest rates
it seems like a slam dunk
well uh you know all i say i'll come
back to what i've said they pay higher
tax already a higher headline rate of uh
of corporation tax bp will pay a billion
pounds in tax on those um north sea
revenues you say that they would like to
be taxed more i mean of course
well they would be willing to pay more
tax and it wouldn't affect their
investment decisions but you know rishi
sunak when he makes these decisions has
got to be thinking about the sector as a
whole
and what one company might say may not
apply to others and what we do need is
to see these companies investing in the
north sea so that we don't become
dependent on other countries for our oil
and gas it's important we've got that
gas and oil is going to play an
important role during our transition to
net zero particularly with the
importance of hydrogen power and things
like that so we have to be able to have
that investment during this period but
underlying profits for bp more than
doubled to 6.2
billion dollars in the first three
months of this year i'll say those
figures again more than doubled to 6.2
billion dollars in the first three
months of this year and yet in 21st
century britain we've got pensioners
riding around on a bus to keep warm
well my understanding that is a global
um profit figure and if you look at the
the north sea figure it is lower than
that but they are going to pay a billion
pounds in corporation tax on that north
sea
yes i i know and our view and you know
the view that risky students take in the
moment is they're already paying more
tax increasing that tax rate might uh
deter investment and also uh introducing
a windfall tax may not actually
raise a huge amount of extra money and
you these are always difficult balance
judgments why then if that's the case
why did uh why did george osborne think
it was a good idea and why did even
margaret thatcher think it was a good
idea well it was a different era and a
different time and um we actually do
have higher rates of tax on oil
companies at the moment sounds like
you've ruled it out
uh well nothing's ever obviously uh
ruled out um the tax system's kept under
constant review we have two
um you know key fiscal events uh yeah
the uh the autumn budget and the
statement are you let's talk about the
local elections are you worried about um
sinn fein being on the brink of victory
in northern ireland
well look um these are democratic
elections we've got a a very clear
approach uh in northern ireland under
the belfast good friday agreement where
you have our power sharing um so whoever
the largest uh party will be there must
be a power sharing executive that's how
things
are established in northern ireland and
obviously what we want to do and it's
for the people of northern ireland to
decide who their representatives are
what the makeup of that is but it's very
important that whatever's decided
respects both communities that's always
been the case it's an absolutely
critical component of the good friday
agreement and we're really committed to
trying to make that northern ireland
protocol work better to improve the way
that's interpreted to get an agreement
with the european union to ensure that
the goods can flow
and that some of the you know rather
ludicrous things that we see like them
banning the sale of seed potatoes and so
forth which makes no sense at all that
we can actually remove that okay i
suppose i'm taking you back uh to the
fact that if shin fein win the local
elections in northern ireland they want
a border referendum if there's a border
referendum then it is likely that we
will see an island of ireland united
which would mean that this prime
minister potentially
was the prime minister in charge of
overseeing the split up of the union and
then who knows what might happen in
scotland
well look um let's take one thing at a
time i think from from the reports that
i've seen uh in all that and you can't
tell let's wait and see first of all
what happens uh on thursday but i think
it's also the case that quite a lot of
people are trying to acknowledge that's
a possibility well it's a possibility
obviously that shin plane will be it's a
it's a democratic election and then
obviously a border referendum um and
then you don't know what would happen
want to board a referendum don't they
say that you'd be heading down it that
direction a lot of the support of what
might happen dude well a lot of the
people i think in the northern ireland
election this time uh you know are not
um you know voting uh for once through
through the prism of um either
uh you know being nationalists or unions
i understand that but although that's
the way that they're going to think
about a referendum
well look we will we will deal with
whatever um we're faced with after we
have the um the results on thursday so
what is the government position on the
reunification of ireland
well northern ireland is part of the
united uh kingdom we're committed to
democratically they choose to be part of
after a border referendum they they then
decide to be part of a united island
then what's the position because you
said it would be a democratic election
of course you believe in in democratic
elections um but but whether or not it's
not such a far-fetched from whatever
whether or not
whether or not to have a referendum is
always a matter for the uk government
always has been
foreign
we haven't gone into that we will wait
and see
what happens when we have that uh
election uh on on thursday as i said
many uh people in many communities
northern ireland are not so it's
democratic until it's not they're not
voting this way necessarily uh on the
basis of whether people are nationalist
uh or whether they're unionists uh
sometimes they're voting for a local
candidate uh you can't read too much uh
into that election result based on the
parties that are there and whichever
party comes out as the largest party you
know the power sharing executive will
carry on as it has done previously
fascinating debate unfortunately we're
out of time so i'm going to have to let
you go i'm actually going to ireland on
friday to uh chat on the late late show
and i know they'll ask me about this
which is why i was pressing you this
morning thank you very much thanks a lot
let's have a look what the papers are
doing this morning and the guardian
quotes president joe biden insisting
that the leaked decision from the u.s
supreme court which looks set to
overturn women's
nationwide access to abortion imperils
civil rights
vps first quarter earnings just talking
about that weren't we six billion
dollars are prompting fresh calls for a
windfall tax to be imposed on the oil
giant with the aim of helping the public
pay their energy bills that's according
to the ft
mirror questions whether the pm will
step in on the rising cost of living
saying the situation was beyond pathetic
but the express has exclusive comments
from the pm who pledges to fire up the
economy to beat the cost of living
crisis
the eye says the government's plan to
send migrants to rwanda is in chaos
after number 10 was forced to admit no
deportations will take place for months
despite a target for the end of may
the man who can't answer a straight
question who are we talking about well
in this instance the daily mail again
taking aim at kia stammer over beergate
and a reminder that just under a
fortnight we'll be taking the show on
the road for a special series of
programmes i'll be going back to my
roots and finding out how the good
people of wigan feel about the cost of
living crisis do let me know if you'd
like to get involved by sending me a
tweet and that's going to be here on sky
news at the usual time from the 16th of
may
still to come on the program for you
this morning with the u.s supreme court
reportedly set to overturn an historic
law that legalized abortion i'll be
speaking to a former republican state
chairman and a former democrat senate
member about what is next
for women's abortion rights
then i'll be speaking to the author of a
new book that hopes to bring gender
equality to the workplace
[Music]
and in the next hours campaigning for
local elections enters the final day
joined by the labour shadow chancellor
rachel reeves
russian forces have stepped up their
assaults on the as of style steel plant
in ukraine's besieged city of mario paul
where 200 civilians remain trapped
including children president zielenski
says 156 civilians have managed to
escape from the bunkers and have finally
reached the city of zaparizia
in mario paul civilians have been
trapped in tunnels beneath the steel
plant with the last remaining ukrainian
forces surviving in horrendous
conditions
following tense negotiations evacuations
finally began on saturday when a convoy
of buses and ambulances began a rescue
mission
156 people put on buses and taken to the
relative safety of the
russian-controlled village of bessie men
and the city of zafarizia but anyone
still in mario paul can't now get out
without another cease-fire
alex is dinipro for us uh this morning
and those people that are still trapped
in mario paul surviving in horrendous
conditions i believe alex good morning
the conditions inside the as of style
plant are as you say absolutely
horrendous and they are getting worse
all the time the humanitarian situation
is extremely dire we have seen this
uh being played out really almost in
slow motion we've seen things posted on
social media over the last few weeks
we've seen fighters inside who've lost
limbs others who have wounds that are
starting to rot they are gangrenous
because they can't get the
medicine and medical treatment that they
need and of course inside with them are
we think
about 200 civilians what happens to
those people
we simply don't know at the moment they
are trying to negotiate another
ceasefire
the diplomacy on that front is faltering
we have seen after the last evacuees
managed to escape
the russians have resumed very heavy
shelling and aerial bombardment of that
plant satellite images incidentally show
the extent of the devastation and damage
whole areas of that complex have
literally been obliterated by the the
very heavy bombing now i was in zapposia
yesterday and i spoke to a number of
people who'd managed to escape and they
described
the trauma of what it was like to be
inside many of them were getting off the
buses after they arrived in the relative
safety
of the un reception point which had been
set up in a shopping center they were
confused in some cases
others didn't really know what to make
of all the waiting press they didn't
really quite understand
how much their story had captured the
world's attention but every single one
of them absolutely relieved uh to be out
of there they told me that uh they could
put up in some cases it's hard to
believe with the shelling
but it was the the big bunker busters
that really uh brought the horror home
because they you know the wall shaped in
some parts the bits that they were in
started to fall down but the concern now
of course is for those people still
trapped inside and we just do not know
at this moment whether the diplomacy
will be able to reach another agreement
for them to get out
okay alex when i thank you thanks a lot
well in other developments in ukraine
explosions were reported in the western
city of lev overnight the city's mayor
said that three electricity substations
were damaged by a missile strike he
urged people to stay in bomb shelters
ukraine says that more than 20 people
have been killed in an attack on the
donetsk region the region's governor
says another 30 people were also injured
after russian troops shelled a chemical
plant in advica
protests have been taking place in
cities right across america after a
leaked ruling from the supreme court
suggested that abortion rights could be
overturned the draft is not a final
ruling but if it is confirmed up to half
of u.s states could ban abortion the
ruling has been widely criticized and a
new poll has found nearly two-thirds of
americans are more likely to back
candidates in the november midterm
elections who support the right to
abortion
women's rights in america are under
attack
if the court
overturns roe v wade
it will be a direct assault on freedom
and join us a little later on in this
hour when we'll be delving quite a lot
deeper actually into the debate around
u.s abortion law with the republican
strategist amy tarkanian and the former
democratic member of the ohio senate
that's caprica faro
some of britain's most high-profile
killers are to have their sentences
reviewed
five convicted murderers are having
their cases looked at among them are
wayne cousins who received a whole life
order for the abduction and murder of
sarah everard the killers of
six-year-old arthur labino hughes will
have the appeals of their sentences
examined as well as well as ian stewart
who was convicted of the murder of his
wife in 2010
and his new fiancee six years later
and judges will consider whether the
sentence for jordan monahan who murdered
his partner and two children was too
lenient
and looking at some other headlines for
you this morning now prince william has
called for more action to prevent male
suicide and says society is not tackling
the issue as fast as we need to
the duke of cambridge made the remarks
during his visit to a new help center in
london he said men can sometimes forget
about the bigger picture but having
support can help them move forward
elon musk has said that businesses and
governments may soon need to pay a
slight fee
to use twitter he maintained the site
would remain free for casual users and
has previously said he would introduce
new premium features such as an undo
tweet button bookmarks and a reader mode
the united states embassy in cuba has
started issuing visas for the first time
in more than four years washington
closed its consular services in the
cuban capital in 2017 after u.s
personnel and their families suffered
from mystery illnesses subsequently
known as havana syndrome
south korean and japanese officials have
said north korea has launched a
suspected ballistic missile towards its
east coast
our asia correspondent tom cheshire is
standing by for us in beijing this
morning hi tom a very good morning not
now north korea what's going on
morning okay i mean this is part of a
concerted uh campaign of pressure that's
been building up um all through this
year recently really this is the tenth
test this year kim jong-un the leader of
north korea has vowed to build his
country's nuclear capability at the
fastest pace possibly certainly keeping
true to his world with this latest test
um in terms of this missile it's
probably not massively concerning in and
of itself uh beyond the capability it is
demonstrating it looks like from its
trajectory it reached about 800
kilometers high in the air traveled
around 500 kilometers there it might be
a medium-range ballistic missile so not
the intercontinental ballistic missiles
we've seen them test already this year
which have a much further range which
could in theory strike the us mainland
which has always been a worry for the
white house the question is why is he
keeping up with this campaign i think uh
a large part of that is to do with the
new president um who will be sworn in in
south korea uh yunsuk nyo he's taking a
hard line in the in his leadership
campaign he's vowed to increase military
spending we've also seen similar things
from japan in terms of their looking
around looking at china looking at north
korea wanting to increase their own
military spending so this is probably uh
north korea reminding them of that
capability especially as president biden
is due to visit south korea and japan
next week this is north korea rattling
at sabre again saying we still don't
have a deal and we're still a nuclear
power okay for now thank
you the rocket has been caught mid-air
by a helicopter
okay
let's find out what happens here we go
how can it have been caught oh i see oh
i see i get it i get it rocket labs
helicopter crew attempted to grab hold
of the parachute lines with dangling a
cable and a hook this was part of the
company's cost-saving approach to
recover used rockets so they would not
have to rebuild them
from scratch
the helicopter caught the falling rocket
before being forced to drop it for
safety reasons about 20 seconds later
i thought it meant that the helicopter
caught the images of the rocket it was
like okay happens all the time but i see
now what they meant now amber hood is
expected to take the stand on the 14th
day of johnny depp's defamation trial
against her the actor is suing his
ex-wife for 50 million dollars over a
domestic abuse article she wrote in the
washington post meanwhile she's
countersuing 400 million dollars here's
katie spencer
the witnesses for johnny depp finished
in court amber heard's team hit back
calling on the judge to dismiss the case
altogether mr depp hasn't introduced any
evidence and there can't be a reasonable
inference drawn that would permit a jury
to find by that he's proven by clear and
convincing evidence that miss heard
wrote the
words their grounds how depp's team had
shown that the washington post article
including its controversial headline
wasn't written by heard the only
evidence
that has been presented in this case
your honor by mr dougherty was that the
op-ed wasn't misheard's idea that the
aclu asked her to write the op-ed and
indeed that they even wrote the first
draft and then that miss heard vetted
the finished article with her lawyers
and with lawyers from the aclu to make
sure that it wasn't problematic that is
the only evidence in the record
depp's legal team's response this was
just a scam for her to get the seven
million dollars in the divorce
settlement that she said she gave to the
aclu she swore she gave to the aclu and
the children's hospital of los angeles
and she pocketed
with the judge dismissing two of the
motions but promising to take advice on
a third herd's team brought their first
witness an expert on intimate partner
violence whose psychological evaluation
concluded heard had ptsd from depth
controlling behavior no matter what show
she was filming or shooting he would
call the leading actor he would call the
director he would tell you i got eyes
down there i got eyes down on the set um
so she never felt safe to be herself and
be an actress
the couple's marriage described as a
damaged relationship punctuated by
coercive control as this defamation case
continues
katie spencer sky news
fascinating stuff isn't it uh what about
the weather is that let's see
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
britain will see showers developing
widely today after a dull wet start for
many but it'll turn mostly fine later on
mild but cloudy with outbreaks of rain
over northwest central and southeast
britain and fog on the hills
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
lily's put some pictures together again
for us this morning this is what they
look like the telegraph love this
story christopher hope who we know of
course on this program who is the deputy
editor of assistant editor i should say
of the telegraph this is his uh good
lady that's sarah hope the wife as i
said of the papers assistant editor she
was awarded an mbe from prince charles
at windsor castle yesterday after
setting up a charity to help improve the
lives of child amputees across the world
do you remember you'll remember the
story uh the charity launched after um
losing her mum in a bus crash in 2007
and the accident which also left her
two-year-old daughter pollyanna needing
to have a right leg amputated thanks to
prosthetics pollyanna is now an
accomplished ballet dancer and we've
seen images of her of course on the show
previously congratulations
you might want to check your cupboards
after this vas that's stood in a british
surgeon's kitchen for 40 years could
fetch up to 150 000 pounds at auction it
was purchased in the 80s for a few
hundred pounds little did the buyer know
it's actually a rare 18th century
chinese artifact
they'll be saying that about kay buddy
at breakfast mugs in future and fancy
fish food i don't know why you're
laughing again fancy fish for breakfast
well this huge bald eagle certainly did
this remarkable picture was taken by
bird photographer mark costa and that
was in scottsdale in arizona moments
after the raptor
swooped this catfish the bald eagle is
america's national symbol and locals
have fondly named this one bandit
so in the last half an hour the
environment secretary has told this
program george eustis of course about
what he thinks might happen in the local
elections
more widely but also specifically in
northern ireland how concerned are they
if uh sinn fein wins that election that
there could be a border referendum to
potentially unite the island of ireland
this is what he had to say
whether or not to have a uh a referendum
is always a matter for the uk government
always has been
foreign
we haven't gone into that we will wait
and see
what happens when we have that uh
election uh on on thursday as i said
many uh people in many communities
northern ireland are not so it's
democratic till it's not they're not
voting this way necessarily uh on the
basis of whether people are nationalist
or whether they're unionist sometimes
they're voting for a local candidate uh
you can't read too much uh into that
election result based on the parties
that are there
oh tomorrow thoughts yes a cabinet
minister saying that a border pole in
northern ireland is a possibility i mean
of course that is just a fact because um
you know only the northern ireland
secretary can call that border pole if
there is a majority in northern ireland
in favor of it and of course you'd have
to have a referendum in northern ireland
and in the republic of ireland so we're
a long way down the track but could the
first move happen this week if as polls
suggest sinn fein win the most seats in
the local elections in northern ireland
on thursday we'll find out out those
results friday night into saturday
george easter says we'll deal with
whatever we are faced with at that point
and it will be a huge task they are
faced with because the expectation is
that the unionists would decline to
serve in a power sharing administration
with sinn fein if they had the first
minister therefore you'd have turmoil
potentially for months afterwards and of
course huge pressure to renegotiate the
brexit agreements this infamous protocol
that boris johnson signed up to and is
proving very unpopular with unionists so
that could be the most consequential of
the local elections that we have this
week and with tomorrow's take um um in
the nine o'clock hour i want to ask you
about the fact that he says that he
feels that the old companies are paying
enough tax for now but we'll come back
to that we'll come back that's okay
meantime what do the people of northern
ireland think ahead of the local
elections uh tomorrow who better to find
out than our very own david blevins
[Music]
for some there's only one election issue
the brexit border separating them from
great britain
but there are other pressing concerns
even in unionist heartlands the
protocols bank has no doubt that but to
me the housing issue is the the biggest
household the biggest issue in this area
i like to say it's getting equal in
quality for both sides yes no yes and i
think the number one factor is
the living issue yeah the electric and
the gas what they do for my community
they don't do nothing for my community
they only come around the door when
they're looking their phone
irish nationalists are poised for a
historic victory but shin feins michelle
o'neill can only become first minister
if unionists form a government with her
father martin mcgill fears more
political stalemate he rebuked
politicians at journalist lira mckee's
funeral for not coming together sooner
why in god's name
does it take the death of a 29 year old
woman with her whole life in front of
her
the priest says political vacuums are
dangerous in northern ireland
i have to say my my blood would run cold
i would put it to strongly isn't that
with the idea of steel mate
still mate here has left us in some very
very
dark places so if they're still made
that if our politicians refuse to do
that then we
then they provide a grind where the
likes of those in organized crime gangs
will flourish
in the last stormont election the
democratic unionist party won 28 seats
shinfan 27 but the dup is under pressure
over brexit there are two more moderate
parties the ulster unionists and the
nationalist sdlp and alliance its middle
ground vote steadily increasing
freya mcclement's northern editor of the
irish times says ashinfe and wynn would
write a whole new chapter here
it plays into the question of a border
pole a unity referendum whether there
should be a united ireland because
that's the conversation that was put
really firmly on the agenda by brexit
that conversation is not going away and
you'll hear the dup very vocal on this
saying if there's a nationalist first
minister it brings that border pool
closer
brexit and the resulting border in the
irish sea have been political game
changers here one driving nationalist
demands for irish unity the other
fueling unionist fears about their place
in the united kingdom and that creates
the potential for this to be a defining
election
for a hundred years stormed elections
have been won by pro-british parties
victory for an irish nationalist party
holds out the prospect of real
constitutional change
david blevins sky news at stormont
now overwhelmed by work and endless
to-do lists the group of women got
together to get their work lives under
control choosing to focus on what
mattered most to their careers they
vowed to say no to new requests for
dead-end work and so the no club was
born let's talk about it should we in
more detail
lise vesterlund professor of economics
at the university of pittsburgh and
co-author of the no club putting a stop
to women's dead-end work is with us hi
it's great to see you thank you for
joining us on the program tell us more
about the no club
so the no club formed about 12 years ago
where um i and three of my friends all
realized that we were uh spending
endless hours and um trying to sort of
knock out to-do lists that really were
not core to our jobs and what we
realized was that
what was keeping us busy was what we
characterized as non-promotable work
that is work that was important to our
organizations but wasn't important
uh to our careers
and in that process we uncovered that we
were not the only women who were
suffering
from this work in fact it turns out that
any profession that we looked at
um had women over burdened with this
work uh so it didn't matter if you're an
architect an engineer or an academic
or supermarket clerk women everywhere
were doing um an exceedingly large
amount of this work
and an amount of this work that was much
larger than their male peers
and what do you say to women who feel
that they can't say no
that's a very uh real fear because what
we show in our research is that women
are not doing this work because they are
better at it or because they enjoy it
but rather because we all expect them to
do this work
so saying no can be quite dangerous
because you are at the risk of backlash
because everyone is expecting you to
take on this task so by declining the
work
you are in fact sort of violating the
norm that everybody holds of you so
part of what we're arguing in the book
is that this is not a fixed women
problem where we need women to say no
more often but rather it's a
question of fixing the institutions that
they work in
where we all
rely on women to sort of keep the
machinery going but don't reward the
work that they do to do to to keep it
going and what can men do to help
but what men can do to help
yes
um they they can come forward and
help out
so um you know one of the things that we
we talk a lot about is that or that we
certainly have seen in our own work is
that
we don't seem to recognize that women
are carrying this exceedingly large
burden and
once we become aware of this problem we
have seen in many organizations that
rather than asking for volunteers in a
meeting that we start taking turns if we
draw names out of a hat
um so
recognizing that whenever it comes not
just to the holiday party but also to
assigning that low revenue
time-consuming client that we are
um sort of inclined to give it to the
females that will make
all of us including the men aware that
we shouldn't just give the work to the
women because what we ideally should be
doing in organizations if
to give it to the
employees who is best at it not to the
one who's least resistant to take it on
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the programme thank you okay
thanks for having me thank you
return now to the story that a leaked
draft opinion document suggests the
supreme court is set to overturn a
historic law that legalized abortion
joining us now is republican strategist
amy tarkanian and a former democratic
member of the ohio senate capri cafaro
hello tibo thank you so much for taking
the time to join us on the programme
this morning um looking at some
percentages um a survey
saying that uh 40 just over 40 percent
uh of americans said the country would
be a worse place to live if the us
supreme court overturned roe v
wade which uh for the benefit of my
viewers here legalized abortion of
course um amy to you first of all why
are they wrong
well they're wrong because if this is
overturned it does not take away the
actual abortion uh legality it just it
takes it back to the states so each
state will be able to make that decision
on whether if they eliminate it actually
altogether which i highly doubt um we
will see much of that if at all
it will actually leave it up to the
citizens to decide is it okay to have an
abortion in your first trimester second
trimester third trimester where is that
fine line that we draw
and so i think the fact that this is a
scare tactic that the left is using by
trying to divert from the many failures
of the democratic administration leading
into the midterms this is their way of
basically dangling a carrot and trying
to divert from all the other failures
and saying hey republicans they don't
care about you uh they don't like you
when it's quite the opposite
okay capri what do you think of that
first let me say a few things i mean we
we have no idea who is behind the leak
of this document it has been apparently
authenticated by chief justice john
roberts so there's obviously some truth
behind the content of this um i
certainly hope and i know that there's
been a lot of uh concerned at least
expressed by conservatives that this
leak is something that is very uh
concerning um we've already heard from
the courts that they are going to try to
figure out who's done this and
adjudicated so let's put that to the
side for a moment
um and and simply say a few things one
um the fact that the the states will
actually you know if roe v wade is
overturned uh the states would have the
ability to make that decision they're
already doing that in a number of states
across the united states have
placed significant limitations
on access to abortion rights at this
point so that i think at this point will
set up the american electorate for some
significant concerns about inequity and
access to abortion services
concerns about the ability to access
contingent upon not only geography but
economy no question about it the
democrats have an uphill battle in a
midterm election
and i do think that whether or not this
is a scare tactic or not that has been
facilitated by democrats or liberals i
think that the what will result from
this if indeed we do see uh an
overturning at the supreme court level
we will see i think a potential
galvanization of a democratic uh
coalition that would not necessarily
show up in a midterm election there is
absolute malaise amongst democratic
voters right now across the across the
united states low poll numbers for
president joe biden
um not a lot of motivation on behalf of
democratic voters this is an opportunity
i think um and we've we're already
seeing this for galvanization of a
coalition um that has traditionally
brought democrats to victory i still
don't think that there is
any guarantee that this will help
democrats uh actually get over the
finish line um in in the midterms but it
will play a significant role in united
states senate races and places where
there are open seats um because the
senate is really the place that makes
these decisions about uh supreme court
nominees and confirmations okay let me
bring amy back in there land of liberty
of course is how many people see the
united states what do you say to those
who say except when a woman wants to
have at the liberty to decide what
should happen to her own body
well it's going to be
well she have that ability to do it in
the first second or third trimester and
where do you draw the fine line and when
you hear
sorry to interrupt you there amy because
my understanding was and i'm sure you're
going to clarify this for me it was once
a heartbeat had been detected then an
abortion could not be carried out is
that wrong
um yes and then they have actually said
it's the viability of the fetus or the
child and depending on what you believe
i believe that it life starts at
conception and with the way that
technology has improved uh dramatically
we can now actually have a younger child
um that is not out of the womb yet um to
have a higher
chance of surviving we have seen
actually babies as young as 21 and 22
weeks
survive outside of the womb with
assistance so there are more
possibilities now um from when this was
first put into place in 1973.
in 1982 president joe biden then state
senator
actually u.s senator joe biden
even said himself that roe had gone too
far and so i think that it it going back
to the states is going to be incredibly
important and i don't i do believe that
it is not going to take the democrats
over the finish line just like capri had
mentioned
uh capri your thoughts on that
well let me just address the heartbeat
issue first kay so this is an issue that
that has um permeated across a number of
states and and right now a number of
states have placed including the state
of ohio um they've passed things called
the heartbeat bill where um there would
be constraints on access to abortion
services at the time in which a
heartbeat is detected so those type of
constraints already exist
across the state and i think with the
absence of um
federal protections that have been
extended by supreme court president
what we would see as i mentioned earlier
is this patchwork which i think is
concerning a number of women and not
just women i want to go back to that
earlier point about the land of liberty
this does set a precedent not only about
reproductive rights in the united states
but about a number of other rights that
have been extended and protected in
recent supreme court cases including for
example same-sex marriage um and uh the
overfilled decision that uh the supreme
court had passed through in uh 2015 so i
think that there is a lot of concern
that is going to be raised about whether
or not the united states supreme court
can we leave some of these larger uh
issues of protecting rights uh to the
supreme court or will we now see the
overturning of roe versus wade as as a
potential uh open door to unraveling
other protections that have been
extended to a number of different groups
um over the last um you know several
years and decades so i think that the
issues of freedom uh individual choice
privacy all of those things are now i
think up for debate and are raising
significant concerns i do think that it
will
coalesce democrats but i do think and i
i stand by this that the question
becomes will it be enough um in a very
difficult midterm election to actually
make a difference it is right now
motivating the senate the current
senators to try to find a way to codify
reproductive rights in the federal
statute which basically would supersede
anything that the court would do um
that's going to be a heavy lift we'll
see if it happens absolutely fascinating
stuff ladies it's great to hear both
sides of the argument we do appreciate
you uh taking the time to stay up late
or get up early i'm not sure which one
it was to explain your point of view for
us on the breakfast show here in london
this morning thank you
pleasure thank you
thank you
we're hearing from the president of the
european
commissions ursula von de line of course
are speaking right now about eu
sanctions on russia that the united
states announced massive budgetary
support and we as two team europes we
have to do our share too
but then in a second phase
there is the wider reconstruction effort
and you all know that the scale of the
destruction is staggering hospitals and
schools houses roads bridges railroads
theaters factories you just name it so
much has to be rebuilt
of course in the fog of war it is
difficult to come up with a precise
estimate but economists are talking
about several hundred billion euros
and here honorable members
i think europe has a very special
responsibility towards ukraine
with our support
and of course with the help of the
international financial institutions and
other global partners
ukraine can rebuild their country for
the next generation
and this is why today i propose to you
that we start working on an ambitious
recovery package for our ukrainian
friends
if we do it right
this package should bring massive
investments
to meet the needs and the necessary
reforms in parallel
so it should address the existing
weaknesses of the ukrainian economy
and lay the foundation for sustainable
long-term growth
it could set a system of milestones and
targets to make sure that the european
money
truly delivers to the people of ukraine
and is spent in accordance with european
rules
it could help fight corruption we have
to do that it could align the legal
environment with european standards osu
vandalian uh president of the european
commission speaking in brussels about a
package of measures to
harm russia and benefit ukraine when i
say how in russia talking about the
economy of course now
here's the thought how much would you
pay to get your hands on
this here it comes
legendary
piece of football memorabilia what is it
well it's the
shirt the argentina great diego maradona
war during the 1986 world cup
quarterfinal against england that famous
hand of god and the goal of the century
it's estimated to fetch more than 4
million pounds at a sotheby's auction in
london later on the late football icon
swap shirts with england midfielder
steve hodge after full time and he has
been in possession of it ever since who
wants to buy it apparently there's some
argentinians in
stay tuned
[Music]